This video is brought to you by
skillshare,
the first 500 people to sign up with the
link in the description.
We'll get a two month free trial,
a wise crack.
Jared,
again,
southpark creators,
Matt Stone and Trey Parker sure do make
us laugh,
but they make something else to a metric
crap ton of money.
It's a tale as old as time,
greatest stop,
motion,
animated Christmas card,
nab,
comedy central series,
a movie,
an Oscar nomination,
Yada,
and joy.
A collective net worth of $800,
million dollars.
Yet,
despite being an ad supported business
like some other people,
we know south park has never been afraid
to bite the hand that feeds it.
So let's take a look at how stone and
Parker lampooned the financial world
across four of our favorite south park
adventures cash rules,
everything around us in this widespread
condition on economics in south park,
in gnomes,
the sleepy town of South Park readies
itself,
very classic David and Goliath battle,
a real showdown between massive
corporate coffee chain,
hard books and the homegrown mom and pop
coffee shop tweak brother.
You see,
I own a coffee shop and now a great big
multimillion dollar company is going to
move in and try to take all my business,
which means I may have to shut down and
sell my son,
tweak into slavery.
South Park challenges are natural bias
towards the little guy by demonstrating,
hey,
sometimes the little guy is actually a
total asshole and in south park this
particular asshole isn't above keeping
his own son hopped up on caffeine or
exploiting children for the media.
If it helps us business stay afloat,
it's time to stop large corporations.
Prop 10 is about children.
Vote yes on prop 10 or else you hate
children.
The very notion that a small business
might be driven by impure capitalist
motives is a message we're not used to
hearing and the townspeople of Southpark
aren't ready for it either,
which is why the tweak and horror books
rivalry is neatly stereotyped as just
another innocent family business versus
a big fat magic carpet guy from New
York.
In fact,
throughout the episode,
most arguments in favor of big business
are immaturely,
shouted down,
not with reason or facts,
but well with immature shouting.
Oh,
pardon me,
Mr assface.
Anyway,
let's hear your side of the argument.
So who's the real bully here?
GNOMES demonstrates how bald face
appeals to emotion can be used to
disguise the cold hard mechanisms of
profit.
I've got one for you.
How about doing a report on how large
corporations take over little family
owned businesses,
although he may be a staple of the
community who charms people with this
folksy marketing Mr.
tweak proves himself to be an even more
cutthroat capitalist than his rival.
Kids are great to get people on our
side.
You don't just throw a child in a
political commercial to sale your
beliefs and it isn't long before the
preteen protagonists of southpark become
convenient ponds in his agenda as
they're forced to passes anti-corporate
words off as their own,
and as the voluminous corporate
automaton bulldoze its way through
Belgium America.
Perhaps there is no stopping the
corporate machine
knowing much about Mr Weekes true
business practices or even about the
superior quality of the starbucks
coffee.
It doesn't have that blend.
Raw sewage taste that tweaks coffee.
Has the people of South Park demonstrate
a programmatic response that boils down
to simply small business,
good big corporation back.
Does it matter if the big corporation is
actually an ethical business and if the
children in question are foul mouth hell
raisers,
no it doesn't,
and that's thanks to a principle called
the backfire effect which says the
presentation of any new and contrary
information will be dismissed outright
threatens your basic belief structure.
Try arguing with people on facebook
about politics.
We're confident you'll change their
minds.
The gnomes episode of South Park
lampoons.
This idea of hardwired biases by
demonstrating small businesses just like
small children can be just as scummy as
their larger counterparts.
They're just not as prolific about it
because after all,
as the underpants gnomes of the episode
adorably demonstrate both small and
large businesses are geared towards
making a profit even if there might be
some ambiguity about the path toward
that objective,
collect underpants.
Where are the gnomes episode satirizes
exploitation of children for emotional
sympathy,
cash for gold,
satirizes the exploitation of the
elderly for massive profit,
and how better to demonstrate this con
inaction then by way of the home
shopping network.
In this episode stand learns his Grandpa
has routinely fallen victim to
television scams that are draining his
retirement funds.
Meanwhile,
Cartman's rank opportunism drives him to
take advantage of those same scams,
to feed his insatiable greed from these
two angles.
Cash for Gold examines both the Predator
and the prey through the lens of value
theory.
There are different theories of value
out there.
You've probably heard the kind dictated
by supply and demand,
but value might not necessarily be a
financial value,
but instead be rooted in social,
emotional or historical value and much
like financial value,
these alternatives can be situational
and fluid entering on a variety of
intrinsic and extrinsic factors.
Let's take a look at some examples.
After stands,
grandpa give Stan a bolo tie that was
bought off the TV for $6,000.
Stand almost immediately learns that the
very same tie is worth $15 at the local
appraiser.
I'll give you $15.
Then after pursuing third and fourth
opinions stand watches the Bolo Tie
diminish and financial value right
before his very eyes,
until it's worth no more than a seven
layer burrito at Taco bell.
My grandpa paid $6,000
for something barely worth anything.
How does something like this happen?
To answer stands?
Question.
This episode introduces us to multiple
forms of value beginning with the market
value displayed on the home shopping
network.
As Dean,
the home shopping network hosts uses his
authority to convince his elderly
viewers.
They're getting amazing deals.
Those same viewers reliably line dean's
pockets.
Even though what he's selling is in the
frame of material or resale value,
pretty much a piece of crap.
Look at these stunning airings.
These are genuine fo Sapphire earrings,
14 carat gold,
86 karat photo sapphire.
This disconnect is the very mechanism
that drives any great scam,
high perceived value,
married to low actual value where a
purely labor oriented view of economics
might consider the work that went into
producing an item.
South Park here exhibits a more nuanced
idea,
one that proposes value is determined
not by quality or by effort of
production,
but by the nature of supply and demand.
And boy does dean know how to drive and
exploit that demand at that price.
You practically stolen from us.
Ouch.
And later when Stan urges dean to commit
suicide,
you should carry yourself.
Dean is able to conceptualize his life's
work only in the monetary figure it
might draw in a lawsuit.
Two point $7,000,000
for dean.
There's literally no useful value beyond
the financial freedom of value,
just how much cash he can squeeze from
people's wallets.
However,
we clearly see the impact of emotional
value.
When stands,
grandpa tells the story of his dog.
Brilliant.
Did I ever tell you I used to have a
border collie named patches?
Yes,
grandpa.
I love that dog.
She always made me so happy when she
died.
I didn't let myself get too sad because
I thought thought I'd always have the
memory of her slobbery and happy face.
I can't remember what she looked like.
Billy,
through this monologue,
we learn GRANDPA's reckless purchases
have little to do with the perceived
market value of the items in question.
No GRANDPA is trying to add emotional
and historical value to himself by
creating memories and sentimental
connections that will last long past his
death.
Elsewhere in the story,
we learned these fluid and disparate
notions of value call into question the
true value of nearly everything.
We see the perceived cultural value of
an academy award evaporate as it's
simply melted down to be resold in new
forms stands gift to his grandfather.
A framed photo of Grandpa with his
beloved dog arguably has astronomic
emotional value,
but low market value thing completely.
That means a lot and GRANDPA's six grand
gift to Stan is ultimately written off
as being
gay gay,
but
just how loose is that relationship
between labor and profit.
That question sits at the foundation of
go fund yourself,
an episode in which the South Park kids
launched a successful brand that doesn't
even bother to put a business behind it.
A startup company,
a company that does what?
No,
we don't want to do anything.
In fact,
the official slogan of their company is
lacking,
can make their business,
which ultimately calls itself The
Washington redskins draws at success
from the bastardization of modern
kickstarter culture,
accepting monetary donations in exchange
for no effort at all.
Here we cut throat.
The episode southpark suggests that in
the advent of twitter,
facebook,
and Instagram,
the success of a brand or company can
now be routed purely in its appearance
rather than its function.
One of the central arguments of this
episode is that what a business does is
less valuable to that business then the
relative power of its brand.
When Stan sets off to find the perfect
startup name,
this moment carries more important than
any objective pursued by Cartman's
leadership.
It's the greatest startup company name
ever.
What Washington Red Skins,
I'm pretty sure that's taken carmen,
the episodes,
thesis,
mirrors and argument made by
philosophers,
John Boatyard,
who argued in 1981 simulacra and
simulations that all previous
definitions of value had been woefully
inadequate.
Boatyards work presented that value
isn't determined by how much work has
gone into making something or by the
nature of it's materials or by its
overall usefulness.
No value is determined purely as the
appearance of value.
In other words,
according to beaudry art,
an item or brand is only valued as it
exists as an image in relation to other
things that are also images.
Value then is determined only in the
relationship that exists between things
or among a set of things through this
frame.
It's more important for a business to
have a great brand than it is to make
great stuff.
It's more important to be trendy for
investors than it is to make fat.
Stacks of cash.
Uber being worth billions of dollars
while still losing billions of dollars.
Yeah,
Baudrillard more or less predicted that
decades ago in Gofund yourself.
The South Park kids take this concept of
value to absurd heights,
much like the protagonist of Hbo,
his entourage,
they embrace the idea that the ultimate
success lies in not doing anything at
all.
Just startup cash instead out,
bro down,
but we still gotta love them because
like so many in the real world,
the south park kids are just squirrels
trying to get a nut.
Today's economy is awash with side
Hustles,
independent contractors and guest
lecturers,
but economic power lies not with them,
says South Park.
It sits with the fat cats at the top who
know how to work the system with minimal
effort or does it ultimately the kids,
Washington redskins venture is left in
shambles because of the brands.
Missteps on a social issue.
There's nothing sweet about people who
are decimated.
Here are the episode argues that a
business built only on aesthetics has
nowhere to turn and no foundational
beliefs to hold two.
Once public opinion turns against it,
it turns out even a business that does
almost nothing can be threatened by
doing or saying or being the wrong
thing.
At the time in South Park,
that outcome leaves our young
entrepreneurs faded to the worst
punishment of all.
I guess we got to go back to ski scratch
that there is in fact a worse punishment
than going to school and it arrives at
the forefront of the episode titled You
Have Zero Friends.
This episode examines the absurdities of
our growing social media economy as in
the cash for gold adventure.
South Park here tackles head on the true
meaning of value.
Looking on facebook today,
we see that since adding a loser,
kip droughty as a friend dominic,
are our friendships and social worth
measured by our likes and facebook
connections,
or are they determined by the
interactions we share in what the cyber
punk community derisively refers to as
space from the outset of the episode are
protagonists,
stand side by side in the meat space and
debate their respective levels of social
status as quantified solely by their
collections of online friendships.
I don't have any friends
in this framing.
Facebook friendships like money create
an easily measurable hierarchy of
personal value.
I don't know what to do.
I just can't seem to get my friend
numbers to go up.
The truth is,
as long as you have that Kip,
Jordy luther is a facebook friend,
people view your friendship as a
liability.
You've got to dump him.
Cartman unsurprisingly sees
relationships not as intrinsically
joyful,
but as status symbols by which to
elevate some people over others.
If this calls to mind beaudry again,
well,
it should because in his work,
the consumer society yard warned that
instead of enhancing life,
a transactional approach to
relationships leads to an individual
lack.
Since everything possessed is
relativized in relation to others,
cartman's troubling view of
relationships begins to infect even
kyle.
When Kyle's digital farm is depleted due
to economic hardship,
he turns to his long time meetspace
friends,
Stan,
but even after Stan has offered kyle his
real world support,
all kyle can think about is how much his
own social media cache must be
suffering.
Just so confused that I really need a
friend right now.
Okay,
dude,
I'm,
I'm here for you Kay,
so then get on facebook and fertilize my
crops.
Shortly thereafter,
kyle drops the suite,
but socially toxic,
kip from his own roster of facebook
friends in order to salvage his own
social standing south park asks,
who are we really when our online
presence outweighs our real world
engagements,
when he insists her relationship with
Stan,
be validated on the Internet,
and even randy doesn't believe in his
connection with his own son until Stan
agrees to add him on facebook,
so I'm not your friend.
Then
Dad,
you are my friend,
but you just don't want to add me as a
friend
that it's just a stupid click of a
button that takes two seconds,
right?
But you don't have the two seconds or in
our reality and in south park,
this disjunction between our digital and
real world lives threatens to place a
greater premium on our digital behavior
and it makes our physical life seem
significant and less like an experience.
Perhaps.
That's why kyle pushes back against
friendships with real people like
standing kip.
When doing so means preserving his
digital status and while everyone else
is trying to pump up their digital lives
at the expense of their meetspace lives.
Pour,
kip is desperately trying to force his
digital friendship into the meat space
world by taking his laptop to the movies
for the argument in favor of cultivation
of an online brand is as simple as it is
daunting,
although it may not be as authentic as
the quote unquote real you,
your profile,
your cyber influenced cast a much wider
net than you do alone.
So whatever will you do with all of that
incredible power.
Hey,
here's an idea from your very close
friends at wisecrack.
Thanks for watching guys.
Piece like many youtubers,
we often get asked how we make our
videos,
which programs we use and how we learn
to use them.
Many of us are self taught here at wise
crack and these days you can learn just
about anything online.
If you've ever wanted to start a project
or learn a new skill but weren't sure
where to begin,
skillshare can help get you started.
Skillshare is an online learning
community with over 16,000
professional and easy to understand
classes in design,
photography,
business,
and more.
Whether you're already a creator or
you're looking to become one,
you'll find likeminded people with steps
and advice on how to take your ideas to
the next level.
You can take classes on everything from
book binding to introductory html to how
to shoot a movie on a drone,
and if you've got a skill you'd like to
share with the community,
you can teach a class as well.
A premium membership starts at just $10
a month to get you unlimited access to
the full range of courses,
but the first 500 people to click the
link in the description or received a
free two month trial to skillshare and
all its resources.
So head over to sk l dot ssh slash wise
crack to begin your two month free trial
and get learning.
You can download their mobile app and
take classes no matter where you are.
We can't wait to see what you create and
don't forget to subscribe and ring that
bell so you never miss what we create.
Thanks for watching guys.
Catch you all next time.
Peace.